[Music]
he suspects that two of his deputies are
stealing from the cartel or Navarro he
summons the men furious at their
betrayal his temper gets the better of
him
hey Rodney yes well Dan Rodney yes
[Music]
ooh an informant tells me that is what
killed one of them himself and his other
henchmen killed the the other person for
president Gaviria Escobar has gone too
far
he grabs the opportunity to respond and
starts planning his next move they will
need more sir we go together everyone
responsible for security and we said to
work in the presidential palace pretty
much without sleeping for several days
near poor body of the years just under
three weeks later four hundred federal
soldiers approached the prison to
re-arrest escobar and take him to a
secure jail in bogota
with them a to government officials they
present the president's ultimatum to
surrender but Escobar will not be
intimidated
muchachos
[Music]
he takes the officials hostage
and calls his most trusted ally his
sister yeah
Oh marina he said marina the government
of Colombia isn't going to keep their
end of the bargain
he tells marina to call the President
and get him to back down or the hostages
will be shot
[Music]
this time Gaviria is adamant s quest
ella after the abuse is hit committed
his refusal to honor the terms of his
surrender there was no way we would
trust him a louder as marina relays the
bad news
Escobar realizes that all bets are off
he has pushed the president too far
outside 400 armed men wait for the drug
lords next move what they don't realize
is that despite their numbers they are
powerless to stop Pablo Escobar